surprise I'm launching a line of jewelry
am I wearing any jewelry now no did I
think out this announcement video no are
my arms tired
yes hi guys the news grace help me if
you don't know nightmare life is
different now that's right I'm launching
a line of jewelry not only inspired by
my dog but potentially for yours
your dog if you don't my dog we could
all figure that out that's right I got
it why this where did this come from was
like an alien came down and went to a
baseball game or just trying to prove to
everyone that it knows how to do the
wave that today I am created in line of
jewelry aka a couple pieces of jewelry
that are inspired by my dog goose goose
is so many things to me she is loving
she is caring she's high-maintenance
she's sweet she's unpredictable
she's me as a dog so use terms my muse
and created a couple pieces of jewelry
that are available to you right now okay
gala
[Music]
so I have collaborated a bit okay 1984
which is the same jewelry company that
makes all enjoy yourself us jewelry
crystal wolfy hasn't seen it it's
beautiful pieces and we've been working
together for months months and months
and months and months months and months
and months and then also more months to
create these pieces and I am so excited
about them and they're finally available
to you so here we go first of all it
comes in this packaging which I'll show
you close-ups but its sound damn cute it
makes me angry that's how you know it's
good and then when you open this little
box
KaBlam what
there's just grace and goose goodness
spewing out of this treasure trove and I
uh it makes me happy and confused
because happiness is a feeling that's
feeling feelings and things that I don't
closely connect to all the time and ah
yeah it's on this 3-piece pack you get a
goose necklace a pair of moose earrings
and some bone earrings because I have to
you know check her ego sometimes it
can't all be about her and if you didn't
catch that
these are necklaces and earrings that
are renderings of her face
and she has no idea so we've created
these three packs in gold silver and
rose gold because basic Lee that's the
metal that seems to be very popular
right now but but I was thinking about
this let's say hypothetically you don't
give a sh of me or you want to give
something to someone doesn't wish about
me I got you covered not only are we
launching the goose centric line of
jewelry products but I've officially
turned into a professional creep we have
these what are these now that know now
that we nailed it we nailed it these are
best fur and necklace and pet charm set
that's right I'm here to not only
validate would encourage the crazy pet
lover side of you that most people
probably don't understand you know
you're in like elementary school or
middle school or even high school when
you and your best friend has those best
friend necklaces and said like but 4s
ends we've made them for you and your
dog that's right you can have a best
friend necklace and a matching best
friend pet charm that you can put on
your dog or cat's collar and really just
let the world know who your best friend
is and also maybe your
little bit bonkers but in a fun way
these aren't only available in gold and
there's two types there's one that says
best friends and then one that says I
hurt my dog
I hurt my owner and that's my
announcement this jewelry is ready to go
how much does it cost every single one
of these sets cost you get two pairs of
earrings and a necklace yeah a necklace
and a matching charm for your animals
it's a great deal in my opinion so if
you want to order any of these Jewelry
Sets click the link in the description
box below they are all ready to go they
ship within a few days so you can have
them for the holidays they make great
gifts to yourself to others here your
pets to your enemies and I'm excited
about this emotions being happy and
excited is tiring so hope you guys like
them again if you want any of them click
the link in the description box below
they're just great for you and for
others I'm excited about them and hope
you guys are too other than that I don't
know
[Music]